from flames to flash floods just a week
ago staff at this Nature Park were
protecting their animals from oncoming
bushfires now they're having to deal
with another extreme
there's the drain it was also said
absolutely inadequate navigate it look
what's coming in the park a wall of
water staff rushed koalas to safety
while for creatures more used to the wet
it was more about keeping them in their
place heavy rain has fallen across New
South Wales one of the state's worst
affected by bush fires in the state
capital of Sydney residents were
remembering how to use an umbrella the
orange haze that had taken over the
city's skyline now cloudy gray we need a
bit of rain in water to help with the
fires especially because how dry it was
the past couple days and I think it will
help with behaves as well just push
everything further out this is the
wettest day in many many months we've
only had about four days of rain in the
last four months and that rain has been
no the only short and down this is well
and truly the worst Oh for very long
for many in the country the wet weather
has brought relief and joy more a case
of sliding than singing in the rain that
rain has helped douse some though not
all of the raging bush fires but it does
bring with it another set of dangers
with the land so dry and vegetation
burnt away water just bounces off the
ground as firefighters here are well
aware changing weather doesn't
automatically mean changing fortunes